in 2012 Zhong Cheng Yu left his job as
an engineer at a company called asml the
only company in the world that can make
this machine this machine makes the most
advanced semiconductor chips or
microchips in the world after he left
asml he started two new companies one in
the US and one in China us and asml
lawyers would later allege that you
recruited other asml Engineers to his
U.S company
that they brought with them stolen
information about asml's machine and
that it was all backed by the Chinese
government
this story is just one small piece of
China's Monumental effort to transform
one of the world's most Global and
significant Industries semiconductors
but China's effort has increasingly
locked it in a struggle with the United
States this isn't about market share
this isn't about tariffs this is about
security so how exactly did China and
the US enter into a cold war over
computer chips
[Music]
thank you
this is the first semiconductor chip
invented in the 1950s by engineers in
the U.S it's a piece of silicon with
four transistors on it the more
transistors the more powerful the chip
by 1960 Engineers had already made one
with four times the transistors and each
year they figured out ways to add more
so since the early 1960s semiconductors
have improved at an exponential rate
this is Chris Miller author of chipwar
the founder of Intel Gordon Moore
predicted in 1965 that the computing
power produced by a single chip would
double every year or so and that rate
has held through roughly up to the
present
foreign
the first companies dedicated to making
chips were in the U.S where they really
just had one main customer the US
government
the first use cases were actually in
guidance computers that were in NASA
spacecraft as well as in missile system
the complex guidance equipment the
systems the electronics
[Music]
since chip companies were making better
and better chips each year the US
government believed a deep partnership
with them would ensure that it always
had access to the most advanced ones the
US government has believed that
Computing has been a core determinant of
Nations power on the world stage if you
think about the ways that Computing has
been used to crack codes in World War II
or to track Soviet submarines during the
Cold War I think that judgment is
correct at first these chip companies
handled the entire supply chain they
designed the chips manufacture them and
assembled them into a package for
installation into a product all within
the us but by the late 1960s they
realized they could make a lot more
money designing chips for civilian
products like corporate computers they
just had to make a lot more of them and
a lot less expensively
so many chip companies move their
manufacturing and assembly to factories
in Japan Taiwan South Korea and Hong
Kong where labor was cheaper and the US
government encouraged them all these
countries were U.S allies or partners
and this was a way to support their
economies and deepen ties at the same
time it banned these chip companies from
sharing technology with its Rivals the
Soviet Union and China it was a way to
keep them years behind the U.S as ships
Advanced because of Moore's Law Advanced
ships are substantially better than
previous generations if you're five
years behind or 10 years behind you're
actually quite Far Behind The Cutting
Edge but it wasn't long before these
Allied governments began investing in
their own chip companies in the 1970s
and 80s Toshiba in Japan and Samsung and
South Korea began designing and
Manufacturing chips that rivaled the
Americans and in the 1990s a Taiwanese
company tsmc got so good at
manufacturing chips that many companies
in the U.S stopped doing it it meant
that U.S companies were not the only
ones who could make the most advanced
chips anymore
and every country's chip industry was
increasingly reliant on other countries
for the materials software and equipment
needed to make more complex chips
but while the U.S and its allies were
pushing the limits of chip technology
China was lagging behind
in addition to the US blocking it from
accessing chips during the Cold War many
of China's brightest scientists and
Engineers had been driven out of the
country by the dictator Mao Zedong
during the 60s and 70s but over the next
few decades new Chinese leaders pushed
to catch up by the 1990s the Cold War
was over the U.S had become friendlier
with China and it had lifted most of its
export controls and so China enticed
many chip companies to move their
assembly operations to China and by the
2000s China dominated this end of the
supply chain but China was importing
more and more chips to feed its assembly
industry and it put them in a tricky
position the Chinese government had
studied the tech supply chain and they
realized the entire Chinese Tech
ecosystem relied on a foundation of
imported silicon from China's
geopolitical adversaries from the United
States from Japan from Taiwan and
China's leaders concluded quite
understandably that this was a risk they
were unwilling to continue to take so
the Chinese government poured money into
its own ship design and manufacturing
companies which increasingly partnered
with non-chinese firms all in the hopes
of creating a chip supply chain that
existed entirely within China
soon China could design manufacture and
assemble some older generations of chips
mostly on its own
but it was still years away from making
the most Cutting Edge chips
this is one of those chips it's got
around 114 billion transistors on it
remember in 1960 chips had four
Computing capabilities of the future
just like the beauty capabilities of the
past will be deployed to military uses
the problem is only a few companies in
the world are involved in making them
and none are in China
to start only three American companies
make the software needed to design
Advanced chips then turning those
designs into real chips requires a
machine that's only made by one company
asml but this machine requires equipment
that's only made in the US finally only
companies in Taiwan and South Korea can
put it all together and manufacture the
most advanced processor chips
these companies are choke points in the
supply chain and China was totally
reliant on them for advanced chips
in 2019 police in the US went to a red
zong Cheng Yu but couldn't find him
until he appeared later in China as the
CEO of his company that successfully
made software like asmls thanks to help
from the Chinese government his company
was flourishing and his story was just
one of several instances of Ip theft in
the chip industry the Chinese government
has been at the very least passively
supportive but in some cases actively
supportive of Ip theft because the
Chinese government realizes that its
companies are in a position of relative
weakness in order to eventually decrease
its Reliance on this foreign supply
chain China was identifying choke points
like asml and copying them
but the plan backfired and this is
really angered U.S government other
governments and I caused them to take uh
China's subsidies as a more security
focused issue rather than just an
economic issue this was happening at the
same time that the relationship between
the U.S and China was becoming less
cordial and more competitive China's
market distortions and the way they deal
cannot be tolerated a tremendous in
-property theft situation came on here a
trade war between the United States and
China Trump says he plans to impose a 10
percent tariff increase on China if they
don't want to trade with us anymore that
would be fine with me in 2018 the Trump
Administration banned U.S companies from
selling components to ZTE a Chinese tech
company then in 2019 it banned U.S
companies from doing business with
China's biggest tech company Huawei and
its affiliates
these bands nearly bankrupted ZTE and
dealt a significant flow to Huawei in
2022 the next U.S President Joe Biden
targeted China's chip industry more
broadly first it banned all U.S
companies from selling Advanced chips to
China but it also blocked Chinese design
companies from using U.S made design
software and us-made Manufacturing
Equipment Plus it banned global
companies who use U.S semiconductor
technology from selling Advanced chips
to China as well the US was exploiting
these choke points to stop China's chip
industry in its tracks these expert
controls represented a really clear
shift away from The View that ultimately
trade and Tech exchanges with China were
fundamentally positive some to a much
more zero-sum view of the technological
competition next the US passed a law
that would invest billions of dollars
into its own ship manufacturing
companies and finalized a deal with
taiwan's biggest manufacturer tsmc to
build manufacturing plans in the us all
to enable the US to keep racing ahead
China and the US have a pretty similar
view of the political Stakes when it
comes to semiconductors that's why the
US government has made it a priority to
defend the U.S lead
[Music]
but this has also put extraordinary
pressure on another conflict between the
two countries since 1949 China has
viewed Taiwan as a breakaway Province
and is vowed to reunite with it even
threatening Invasion the U.S has vowed
to protect Taiwan but Taiwan also
happens to own the most important choke
point in the chip supply chain Taiwanese
companies manufacture 63 percent of all
chips and about 92 percent of all
advanced chips with companies that are
indispensable to both the U.S and
Chinese chip Industries Taiwan has built
itself some protection but the U.S
export controls forced taiwan's
companies to make a choice defy the US
and keep selling to China or comply and
cut off China from some of its chips so
far they've signaled they'll cut off
China but as China and the U.S Feud over
chips more and more choices like these
are going to be imposed on countries and
companies around the world asking them
to pick sides in what looks a lot like a
new Cold War
[Music]
foreign